cuatro días después del mortífero
terremoto las víctimas se cuentan por
miles en Siria y muchos más han sido
desplazados
esta mujer perdió a su marido y a sus
tres hijos en el terremoto todo su mundo
ha dado una vuelta tras los sucesos del
lunes
todavía no puedo creer que logre salir
siento que sigo atrapada bajo los
escombros
Hola sentí que iba a morir y ahora
Estamos aquí en un refugio no nos queda
nada somos cuatro familias en esta
habitación no nos queda nada
en el Noroeste del país el terremoto no
sólo afectó a los edificios una presa se
abrió por las vibraciones inundando este
pueblo los recientes han quedado
desesperados en buscar ayuda
como pueden ver nuestras casas Están
inundadas y destruidas por el terremoto
y el agua del río a la gente considerada
de ahí afuera Ayúdanos por el amor de
Dios
para muchos la desesperación se ha
convertido en ira en la ciudad Rebelde
de jalem se formó el jueves un grupo de
manifestantes para protestar por la
falta de acción en la zona
han pasado cuatro días desde el
terremoto y las familias siguen en las
carreteras y jardines con este frío los
que no murieron en el terremoto morirán
de frío necesitamos tiendas de campaña
primeros auxilios y artículos de Socorro
solo para dar cobijo a estos niños que
han sobrevivido a esta destrucción desde
entonces un par de convoys de primeros
auxilios han llegado a la zona Aunque
estaba previsto que estos camiones de
refugios y kits de higiene cruzaran
antes del terremoto El director de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud Pedro
azada en un guerrellizos ha anunciado
que se dirige a Siria la OMS ha
advertido una crisis sanitaria
secundaria que amenaza con golpear a
Turquía y Siria tras el sismo